There’s a temptation
to withdraw nationally
each time we are tested.
However, nothing is more futile
than trying to save only ourselves.
Nobody takes leaving their homeland lightly,
not even those who come for economic reasons.
Since the Second World War,
there have never been as many displaced people as today,
around 60 million.
It's a humanitarian crisis we're facing,
with an influx of refugees.
With each crisis,
fears are manifested.
You have to live with fear,
but you must not live dominated by fear.
Isolation and closure
in the internet age are an illusion.
No problems would be solved
but additional serious problems would arise
because the commitment to our values
and thus our identity would be lost.
If we disregard that,
we are betraying ourselves.
Nothing more and nothing less.
Europe was slow to understand
that the tragedies in the Middle East or in Africa
would not be without consequences.
Europe has not measured the hope
that it evokes
and will long continue to evoke.
We must focus our foreign and development policy
much more on solving conflicts
and combatting what causes people to leave.
Only together will we succeed in achieving a fair
and appropriate distribution of refugees
across all member states.
Let's face it,
the Dublin procedure in its current form is obsolete.
Calling into question the free movement of people
by returning to internal borders
would be a tragic mistake.
But claiming...
But claiming that the Schengen area, in its current form,
makes it possible to counter the pressure on its external borders
would be another mistake.
Less than twenty-six years ago,
before leaving office,
François Mitterrand came to speak at the European Parliament.
He said nationalism is war.
His warning still applies today.
The debate is not between less Europe and more Europe.
It is between the affirmation of Europe
or the end of Europe.
Yes, the end of Europe,
that is to say the return to national borders.
More than ever, we need the courage and cohesion
that Europe has always shown when it matters most,
and Germany and France are ready for it.
Let us work on this together
- as Helmut Kohl proposed
here in the European Parliament in 1989
with a view to the changes in Central and Eastern Europe
- and I quote him:
“With wisdom and a sense of proportion,
with ingenuity and flexibility.” Thank you.